Steph Curry been ejected
wow
Steph Curry has been ejected
with 114 to go in Golden State leading
by two
[Applause]
[Music]
believe it's for something he did with
his mouthpiece
[Applause]
what's interesting about that
I don't think that was in reaction to
anything that happened with the official
on that offensive rebound
he was yelling at Jordan Poole to pass
him the ball and Jordan shot it with 12
seconds or whatever on the shot clock
from 28 feet it didn't go in
as Bane misses another free throw he's
normally a great free-throw shooter
so you see the shot by Poole and Steph
is clapping for the ball pool doesn't
hit it and that's where Steph is upset
so you're right JJ not anything directed
at the officials but just the act of
throwing the mouth guard from his shot
goes into his move
[Applause]
you can't throw your equipment